Adam and Ashley from Burlington Ontario
Canada we're here
where's Burlington it's outside Toronto
West what at west of Toronto is that
near is it near London at all London
Ontario not that far away okay because
I'm gonna be in London Ontario next
weekend what are you doing there there
if the Forest City Comicon they asked me
to come up and be a guest at their
comic-con this week I'm going up to do
another episode of Supergirl how
exciting I had up on Wednesday to
Vancouver and I just I think the script
is coming in this weekend let's can't
wait man I haven't done one in a since
this time last year
we're longtime listeners is the second
show we've attended last being the 200th
episode in Toronto
we're on our way to explore Hawaii for
two weeks or what we feel is an overdue
vacation I thought what better way to
kick off our vacation than to stopover
in LA for a night to attend the show
well thanks guys for coming out there
also may it be a hidden agenda to our
trip to start trying to turn our dynamic
duo into a trio yeah
there's two ways I can take that either
you're you want a 3-way or you're or
you're gonna are you gonna make a baby
which which one is it a little bit of
both
oh my god you're gonna let a stranger
coming your wife that's hot that's so
[ __ ] hot little wait is that hot baby
batter man why do you want to stranger
baby no no no Street you coming to
Netflix this fall straight your baby is
that what you're looking for thought she
knew her baby
but it was a stranger baby you're
looking for a third man this is the town
to do it I mean you guys are what
normally from [ __ ] Canada we're shits
all straight up and whatnot this is the
town to get extra dick in man so we're
looking for or you're looking for a lady
a lady how quickly he yelled that lady
coward
yeah man if you're gonna be here in Los
Angeles welcome to Hollywood put a dick
in your mouth right but if you want to
be all conventional and get a lady can
Adam West's Batman and Bane offer us
some advice on how to increase our
chances sure I guess they can hello
Ashley and Adam I don't go in for these
sort of shenanigans love should be
between two people a man and a slightly
more effeminate man
well I do go in for these sort of
shenanigans
Spain you evil to feed no no no I just
want to see these people get what there
was a third but don't be a [ __ ] bring a
man to bed perhaps even a bat man or get
yourself a young Ward and an old
Englishman that's a hot three-way yes
you'll find him sliding down their
bat-poles
oh thanks for coming out guys we
appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you